let's move on to the next section
containerizing and orchestrating apps
with gke
in the section of the course you'll
learn about containerization and how to
leverage Google kubernetes engine
we've already discussed the spectrum
between infrastructure as a service and
platform as a service
and we've also discussed compute engine
which is the is offering of Google cloud
with access to servers file systems and
networking
now you'll be introduced to containers
in gke which is a hybrid that
conceptually sits between the two
offering the managed infrastructure of
is with the developer orientation of a
pass offering
is let you share compute Resources with
other developers by using virtual
machines to virtualize the hardware
this lets each developer deploy their
own operating system or Os
access the hardware and build their
applications in a self-contained
environment with access to Ram file
systems networking interfaces Etc
this is where containers come in
the idea of a container is to give the
independent scalability of workloads and
pass in an abstraction layer of the OS
and Hardware in is
a configurable system lets you install
your favorite runtime web server
database or middleware
configure the underlying system
resources such as disk space disk i o or
networking and build as you like
but flexibility comes with a cost
the smallest unit of compute is an app
with its VM
the guest OS might be large even
gigabytes in size and take minutes to
boot
as demand for your application increases
you have to copy an entire VM and boot
the guest OS for each instance of your
app which can be slow and costly
now with app engine you have access to
programming services so you only need to
write your code in self-contained
workloads that use these services and
include any dependent libraries
this means that as demand for your app
increases
the platform scales your app seamlessly
and independently by workload and
infrastructure
this scales rapidly but there's no
option to fine tune the underlying
architecture to save cost
a container is an invisible box around
your code and its dependencies with
limited access to its own partition of
the file system and Hardware
it only requires a few system calls to
create and it starts as quickly as a
process
all that's needed on each host is an OS
kernel that supports containers in a
container runtime
in essence the OS is being virtualized
it scales like pass but gives you nearly
the same flexibility as is
this makes code Ultra portable and the
OS and Hardware can be treated as a
black box
so you can go from development to
staging to production or from your
laptop to the cloud without changing or
rebuilding anything
as an example let's say you want to
scale a web server
with a container you can do this in
seconds and deploy dozens or hundreds of
servers depending on the size of your
workload on a single host
that's just a simple example of scaling
one container running the whole
application on a single host
however you'll probably want to build
your applications using lots of
containers each performing their own
function as is done when using a
microservices architecture
if you build applications this way and
connect them with network connections
you can make them modular easily
Deployable and scaled independently
across a group of hosts
the host can scale up and down and start
in stop containers as demand for your
app changes or as hosts fail
kubernetes is a container orchestration
tool you can use to simplify the
management of containerized environments
you can install kubernetes on a group of
your own managed servers or run it as a
hosted service on Google Cloud on a
cluster of managed compute engine
instances called Google kubernetes
engine more on that shortly
kubernetes was built by Google to run
applications at scale
it lets you install the system on local
servers in the cloud manage container
networking and data storage deploy
rollouts and rollbacks and monitor and
manage container and host health
a software Container makes it easy for
teams to package manage and ship their
code
they write software applications that
run in a container the container
provides the operating system needed to
run their application
the container will run on any container
platform
this can save a lot of time and cost
compared to running servers on Virtual
machines
like a virtual machine imitates a
computer
a container imitates an operating system
everything at Google runs on containers
Gmail web search maps map reduce batch
Google file system Colossus and even
Cloud functions which are VMS and
containers
Google launches over 2 billion
containers per week
Docker is a tool that puts the
application and everything it needs in
the container
once the application is in a container
it can be moved anywhere that will run
Docker containers any laptop server or
cloud provider
this portability makes code easier to
produce manage troubleshoot and update
for service providers containers make it
easy to develop code that can be easily
transferred and run both in the cloud
and on a customer's on-premises servers
kubernetes is an open source container
orchestration tool for managing a
cluster of Docker Linux containers on a
single system
it can be run in the cloud and
on-premises environments
it's inspired and informed by Google's
experiences and internal systems
Google kubernetes engine or gke is a
managed environment for deploying
containerized apps
it brings Google's latest Innovations in
developer productivity resource
efficiency automated operations and open
source flexibility to accelerate time to
Market
gke is a powerful cluster manager and
orchestration system for running Docker
containers in Google Cloud
gke manages containers automatically
based on specifications such as CPU and
memory
it's built on the open source kubernetes
system making it easy for users to
orchestrate container clusters or groups
of containers and it also gives
customers the flexibility to take
advantage of on-premises hybrid or
public Cloud infrastructure